welcome to your mom's house
hey so do you like my jacket I do like
your jacket today it's funny because
when I bought this jacket yeah you were
like you look like MacGyver it's it's
you know what's interesting is that now
that I go back does this is a third
jacket that you mocked me well no one
jacket you put on I go I hate you hate
it yeah I remember that jacket right
I hated that track yeah I know thank you
right and I threw it away promptly
because I don't want you to have to hate
what I'm wearing right but I also you
you told me that you really appreciated
me saying how I felt about it right
because you said that I always liked it
cool
here's the thing though this MacGyver
jacket yeah actually I think looks
really good on I really think it's cool
on the video you know I like it covers
up my fatness and everything and it's a
nice color maybe I like to check it okay
but you didn't before you told me never
to wear this you're like supid you're
may you did it you're so fucking crazy
what are you talking I did I don't wear
that you look stupid like that but you
were like it that you were like you just
want you went thin uh looks like
MacGyver and then I just stopped wearing
it for like a year I don't remember that
at all I don't remember that at all what
happened okay I mean your version of
shit I think it happens in your head you
see it you what are you talking